well Chief of Reason magazine and I'm
tickled to be joined today by Tyler
Cowen professor of economics at George
Mason University well-known blogger at
the marginal revolution contributor to
the New York Times
among other things and proud papa this
week of a brand spanking new book creat
your own economy the path to prosperity
in a disordered world Tyler thanks for
joining reason TV happy to be here
tell us a bit about the basic thesis of
creates your own economy should be
creating their own economy and why in
broadest terms I view this as a book
about the power of the individual the
importance of individual liberty and how
we can all create our own liberties
essentially by using the web in the
information economy to create streams of
meaning we draw disparities from YouTube
from blogs from news websites and to the
outsider it doesn't really look like
very much noble is going on but it's
full of suspense it's full of narrative
it keeps us interested and it's a lot
more fun than a lot of the culture of
the past and part of what my book does
is explains and celebrates what I see is
a new world order and you're drawing a
distinction here between sort of purely
economically measured activity and
commerce and more of people's personal
experience that might not necessarily
have a transaction associated with it
it's a very different kind of economic
problem it's one about filtering in some
ways scarcity is gone you're potentially
overwhelmed by how much there is to draw
from it's an economy of attention not
just an economy of spending money and
you say that there's some kind of
difference the connection between
material wealth and happiness now
partially through the internet or
partially through I presume economic
games is less than ever before can you
tease that out a little bit well due
mostly to the prosperity of capitalism
people like you and I can be just
fantastically happy like I said to your
sofa before this session it's quite
plausible that you are happier than Bill
Gates yeah
you have penicillin you you ride on jet
planes you have your own car maybe not
in Washington but you could and life for
you can be extraordinarily fun and all
this free stuff there now also means the
need to earn money is in some ways
weaker than it was even just 10 years
ago on talk a little bit about the
concept of neurodiversity and the
celebration of that I take it that's a
major sort of sub theme in the book
explain that a little bit by
neurodiversity
we simply mean the notion that people
are born with different neurological
wiring one of the key themes in the book
is to focus on autism and the notion
that autistics tend to be what I call
info wars they love to gather process
order information and one of the points
I make in the book is that we in a
society are becoming more like this
ourselves
so I'm saying in some ways we are
mimicking autistics and I'm saying this
is a good thing so part of the book is
this radical reinterpretation of autism
not seeing it just as a disorder but
that there are a lot of positive
cognitive strengths and people who are
autistic is this semi-related - you know
everyone says that we're a much more ad
D kind of culture now and it's tension
spans are very difficult is that
something that we should embrace or sort
of be more aware of well ad D is another
example of a phenomenon that's usually
called just - disorder but there's
actually growing evidence that a lot of
people with what might be a DD or
something like a DD do extraordinarily
well there was one study that found that
entrepreneurs were especially likely to
have dyslexia having dyslexia makes you
very good at delegating responsibility
and it's possible that a lot of people
with a DD they use what is supposedly a
disorder they use it as a way of
channeling their attention to actually
consume information faster and more
efficiently so I'm not saying that
everything about a DD is necessarily
desirable or that people don't have
various problems but that the
neurodiversity of the human race is very
much an underappreciated asset and
that's part of the theme of the book
tying back to the power of the
individual and our right and privilege
to be different shifting gears just a
little bit since you're a professor of
economics and a and a frequent
commentator on matters of economics you
engage a lot especially I think with
people on
left side of the spectrum liberal
bloggers and other types of people how
do you assess and what are your sort of
hopes and fears right now of the Obama
administration's approach towards
economic policy and the kind of overall
climate in the country for receiving
we're talking about economic policy I'm
terrified about the budget
I think we're spending far too much
money we can't afford it I think the
downturn will last quite some time and
what concerns me most is this way of
doing business where interest groups
companies are expected to be on board
with the program or they are cut out
from the negotiating table to me this is
an extremely worrying development and
even the left will come to regret this
sooner or later and I think it's a
terrible crushing development in our
political culture it's hardly new it
goes back a long time but we're seeing
more of it today than ever before and a
lot of people on the Left who otherwise
advocate for free speech or
accountability in government they're
pretty much silent so to me there there
were some disturbing trends there are
many things I like about President Obama
I think he's a smart guy I think he
wants to do a good job I think he's very
sensible on a lot of matters but on
fiscal policy we are absolutely headed
off a cliff and we're not doing anything
to stop it
you interact as I said before with a lot
of liberal bloggers and engage in
dialogues my very crude impression of
some of that conversation is that
libertarians and free market advocates
were certainly interesting and useful
for a lot of those people during the
Bush administration and that there's
been some intense and effects when
discussing especially Obama's economic
policy to suddenly marginalize the same
people that they were engaging with
before is that just me being defensive
what would you see is as sort of the
relationship between those camps in post
inauguration let's say well the people I
know personally are still as nice to me
as they ever were so I don't have any
complaint is the world out there as a
whole marginalizing market-oriented
economics I think so
there's a sense of the Democrats rule
Congress and hold the presidency they
can just do what they want but
everyone's waking up and right
hey this isn't true those New Democrats
that were just elected are still coming
from conservative districts and what I
see very coming is this massive angst
amongst progressives like we have
powered what do we do with it now we
can't make it work heaven forbid we need
more stimulus we need more everything we
can't blame it all on the Republicans
now and I think this is their core
intellectual crisis in a way just like
for a lot of us the financial crisis was
hard for us to explain or deal with
what's your biggest hope going forward
about you know the individual being able
to create their own economy and how that
might change society and and and you
know international economics for lack of
a better word well I think the way I've
been the new information economy it's
one potential very strong protection
against tyranny because tyranny can
control your education can control your
health care can take away a lot of your
tax money but for the most part tyranny
finds it hard to control what you visit
on the way I've been what you say on the
web China tries to some extent they
succeed there's still plenty of shadow
web sites and other ways to get to
places where people want to go so it's
one of our bulwarks of freedom today and
I think it ought to be appreciated as
such it's a largely unregulated economy
it has some problems that have some
excesses but it's somewhere you can go
where truly the competitive capitalistic
spirit reigns well in an on to the
YouTube economy we're gonna cut this off
before the ten minute mark but thank you
very much Tyler and for recent TV
I am Matt well
you